- Thanks to Curiosity
Stream for supporting PBS.
- Golden Hour, Kacey Musgraves!
- Kacey Musgraves won Album of the Year
at the 2019 GRAMMYs for
her album, Golden Hour,
becoming just the fourth country album
to ever take home that award.
So how did she achieve
this crossover success,
and what does it mean for
the future of country music?
We're going to talk to the producers of
Golden Hour to find out.
- The way that this album came together
with Kacey was just so natural between
the three of us, Daniel,
my co-producer, and Kacey.
- I didn't have low expectations,
like no one's gonna like this,
but I wasn't like, "we're
gonna slay the GRAMMYs".
I never thought that.
- Over the past decade, country music,
the genre of Dolly Parton
and The Dixie Chicks
has been dominated by male perspectives.
In 2015, a radio consultant suggested
country stations shouldn't play
too many females if they
wanted solid ratings,
saying, "the lettuce is Luke
Bryan and Blake Shelton,
Keith Urban... the tomatoes of our salad
are the females."
The year before that,
Maddie and Tae released
"Girl In The Country Song".
They're the mint on the state of females
in country music.
("Girl In The Country
Song" by Maddie and Tae)
- So how does this genre evolve
and sound contemporary
while keeping its identity?
Some people argue that it's
crossing over into Pop.
("Women" by Georgia Florida Line)
And others say it means
doubling down on tradition.
("I Don't Remember Me"
by Brothers Osborne)
Kacey Musgraves shows that this choice is
a false binary by mixing elements of
the past and the future
throughout Golden Hour.
- In a way, I would argue that a lot of
mainstream country is even
more overtly pop oriented.
In mainstream country music, the kind of
country music that's played on the radio,
you hear much more overtly Pop elements
like drum machines and trap.
- Throughout the album,
Kacey Musgraves takes
old traditional sounds and makes them
sound new by recontextualizing them.
- You know, I think Kacey
had a real clear vision
that she wanted to mix those things that
she had on her other albums with some
new sounds to bring those worlds together.
- She previously hadn't
had a lot of, like,
keyboards on her records, and so it's
interesting even just
introducing the piano
and some of the synthesizers,
and she was really
open-minded and free
to explore that stuff.
- Even one of the most
futuristic sounding moments
in that album has roots in the past.
Check out the robotic
vocoder at the beginning of
Kacey Musgraves' song, "Oh, What A World".
("Oh, What A World" by Kacey Musgraves)
- Now check out country legend Pete Drake
in the 1965 country music film,
"Second Fiddle To A Steel Guitar".
("Second Fiddle To A Steel
Guitar" by Pete Drake)
- The vocoder at the beginning.
- That's actually my voice,
which is really weird
to hear now, like, when you hear it at
a live concert or
something. You know, it's
not unusual for me to
hear, like, my drums or
piano or guitar parts that
I might have recorded,
but it's definitely a
different feeling to hear
your voice through a vocoder.
- What was that a reference to?
- I think Kacey just had that idea,
she might've referred
specifically to Daft Punk,
but I don't know, I think she just kind of
identified the vocoder's sound as
something that could sound extra-worldly.
- So while this kind of
effect suggests futurism,
it's also distinctly retro.
In fact, here's what
Kacey Musgraves told GQ
about "Oh, What A World".
It's this trippy
perspective, this sound where
future meets tradition.
One though I had was
what if Imogen Heap made
a country album? Would it work?
Would it make sense?
- Maybe no instrument or
sound is more associated
with country music than
Pedal Steel Guitar.
- In fact, when George
Harrison and Bob Dylan
wanted to make country albums,
they had help from Pedal
Steel player, Pete Drake,
the talk box guy.
However, on Golden Hour,
the pedal steel guitar is
doing something different.
It's used more like a texture,
similar to how a post-rock band
might use a guitar.
Check out the guitar
in this post-rock song
by Sigur Ros.
And here's how Kacey uses
the pedal steel sound
in "Space Cowboy".
("Space Cowboy" by Kacey Musgraves)
- Some bands have experimented with
the texture of their instruments to
create post-rock.
Is Kacey doing a similar
thing with country to
make post-country?
- Country music is a big
part of her story, her life,
and in her heart, she
really loves country music.
We weren't making rules saying we have to
make sure that this appeals to country,
especially because she's never really
been embraced by country radio.
- That's something you guys think about
on a regular basis? The identity of
where you guys are coming from?
- I think it was more of like, her saying
I really do love the
emotion of the pedal steel.
- I think Kacey was
like, look, we're gonna
turn the banjo up, we're
gonna turn the steel up,
so we're gonna let people know those
things are in there, and I think she kinda
wanted to do that because
if you're not mixing
genres, in a way, it's
probably not that interesting.
- Throughout the process,
Kacey made sure that
the experimentation didn't go too far.
- One thing that we always
kinda had joked about
was that Kacey's just really good.
We called her The Axeman because she was
always good at trimming the fat.
- And I think The Axeman
ended up really doing
us a great service because The Axeman gave
us a lot of space in music
in a way that I think
allows people to really lean into it, and
listen to it as opposed to being like,
"whoa, there's all this
music coming at me".
(laughs)
- So Shawn Everett is
credited with Dolphin Magic.
Can you tell us what Dolphin Magic is?
- I don't know if it's
ever been made public,
on this song, "Happy &
Sad", there's a transition
that goes into the chorus that is this
celestial kind of heart sound.
It's lifted from a particular cartoon,
I think there's an image of a dolphin
jumping out of the water
as the sound occurs,
and we just pulled that.
- There may be another
factor that's playing into
the crossover success of Golden Hour.
The rise of the Yeehaw Agenda,
starting on the internet as memes in 2017,
to finding it's viral moment with
yodeling kid, Mason Ramsey in 2018.
(yodeling)
From both Solange and Cardi B wearing
cowgirl outfits to Lil Nas X's Billboard
number one, Old Town Road, being a cowboy
has suddenly become very cool.
This rise of the Yeehaw
Agenda has also opened
the doors for people of
all different backgrounds
to participate in the aesthetic of
country Western music.
When a fan tweeted this,
Kacey responded with this.
- Kacey's lyrics open
the door even further,
the inclusive messages of
songs like her 2013 hit,
"Follow Your Arrow" makes
her a perfect ambassador
for country music to a wider audience.
("Follow Your Arrow" by Kacey Musgraves)
So the sudden love for cowboy style
may have helped her cross over to success,
or she could be part of the reason Yeehaw
became so popular in the first place.
There aren't many artists
who have performed
at the Houston Rodeo and appeared on
Rupaul's Drag Race.
Ellie and I are going to write
a Golden Hour inspired song.
Do you have any tips for us?
- Overall, it's a bit reflective,
and so, you know, just
reflect on your life,
and get out of your
comfort zone a little bit,
and see what's out there.
Acoustic instruments
like the acoustic guitar
is pretty much everywhere.
There's not a lot of cymbals!
- Our job is to do Kacey
Musgraves' style, country.
- I listened to the
album, and made notes on
most of the tracks.
Usually the progressions have four chords,
or five, sometimes just two.
One, six, three, five,
or one, six, three, four,
I wrote.
- She puts a lot of
emphasis on the guitar sound
kinda thing, country music
does that in general,
has a lot of guitar sound, but how we..
- How are we gonna, um, so I have an idea.
- Okay.
- So I think we could
try, at least, pulling off
putting in a guitar. I
own an acoustic guitar.
- Okay.
- I can kinda learn basic
chords, and just strum.
- You have a guitar, and
you're just gonna teach
yourself, you're gonna
strum some chords on
this guitar?
- Why not? Hold on, I have.. hold on.
- You're just gonna teach yourself guitar.
- Yeah, if you just,
okay, so if you just play
just one chord and just
strum it here and there.
(guitar strums)
This is not a good idea right now.
- Country, here we come.
- Before we share what we came up with,
we'd like to thank Curiosity Stream for
supporting PBS. Curiosity Stream is a
streaming service that
offers documentaries
and non-fiction titles from a variety of
filmmakers, including
Curiosity Stream originals.
For example, they have
Unraveling The Creative Mind,
that's about how our world has been shaped
by those who have dared
to think differently.
You can learn more at
curiositystream.com/soundfield.
- Okay, now here's our
Golden Hour inspired track.
(country music plays)
- We need some help with the vocals, so
download our track from our Soundcloud
at the link in the description,
and sing on it.
And here's a little advice
from Daniel Tashian.
- Country music likes
a lot of furniture in
the song, where other
songs talk about feelings
like, country music
likes a lot of objects.